[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour un
nouveau numéro de mode d'emploi votre
magazine consacré à l'emploi et à la
formation professionnelle tout de suite
le sommaire le lancement du summer campe
du numérique une centaine de jeunes
saint quentinois ont commencé leur
initiation aux métiers du numérique une
formation jusqu'au 31 juillet organisé
par saint quentin en yvelines avec les
structures de formation pop school et
o'clock un nouvel exécutif à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines nicolas dainville a été élu
vice président en charge de l'emploi de
la formation professionnelle et de
l'apprentissage
avec lui nous reviendrons sur la
priorité de l'agglomération dans les
prochains mois le soutien à l'emploi
enfin rencontre avec christelle munoz la
nouvelle directrice générale du campus
troisième l'école de l'audiovisuel et
d'arts vivants d'elancourt nous ferons
le bilan de la crise sanitaire sur
l'enseignement et nous parlerons de la
rentrée 2020 dans l'établissement le
seigneur comme du numérique a commencé
lundi 20 juillet à la pépinière
d'entreprises promo paul à montigny le
bretonneux pendant 10 jours des jeunes
âgés de 16 à 25 ans vivant à saint
quentin en yvelines vont s'initier aux
métiers du numérique
un événement organisé par
l'agglomération et encadré par deux
structures de formation pop school et
o'clock or regardez qu'est ce que
représente le numérique pour vous la
première question à laquelle ont dû
répondre une centaine de saint
quentinois âgés de 16 à 25 ans c'est le
début du summer campe du numérique lancé
lundi 20 juillet à la pépinière
d'entreprises promo paul située à
montigny le bretonneux
alors moi savez d'approfondir le domaine
du développement web et du community
manager pour en apprendre un peu plus à
savoir si ça peut me plaire
thomas thomas l3 du coup c'est tout
l'univers global en fait que j'adore et
le fait de pouvoir stocker de de pouvoir
protéger développeur web
expert en cybersécurité en objets
connectés ou encore community manager
les différentes professions auxquelles
vont être initiés les summer camp peur
pendant 10 jours des formateurs des
structures pop school et o'clock vont
assurer cette formation en présentiel ou
à distance
une initiative organisée par saint
quentin en yvelines l'objectif pour pop
school il est simple en fait c'est de
faire du numérique une chance et une
opportunité pour tous c'est à dire que
nous on pense que le numérique doit être
ouvert à tous et qui représente
énormément d'opportunités personnel et
professionnel pour les jeunes et donc
nous notre ambition c'est de
démocratiser l'accès au numérique et de
susciter toujours plus de vocations pour
augmenter leur culture numérique pour
augmenter leur employabilité numérique
bien sûr et puis pour les orienter bien
comprendre aussi les métiers de demain
je vous rappelle que 80% des emplois
demain seront impactés par le numérique
donc c'est leur donner un avantage
concurrentiel sur saint quentin en
yvelines entre 5000 et 6000 emplois ne
sont pas pourvus dans les entreprises
spécialisées dans le numérique
[Musique]
il a été élu cinquième vice-président en
charge de l'emploi de la formation
professionnelle et de l'apprentissage
une élection lors du conseil
d'installation du samedi 11 juillet
dernier au vélodrome nationale nicolas
david est avec nous bonjour bonjour
alors le président jean michel fourgous
a annoncé que l'enjeu prioritaire c'est
l'emploi et la sauvegarde du tissu
économique saint quentinois quelles
actions allez vous mener dans cette
perspective là mais écoutez c'est vrai
que c'est une priorité urgente l'emploi
d'autant plus dans cette crise sanitaire
liée aux copies de 19 qui impacte
beaucoup d'entreprises
on a un taux de chômage élevé qui
malheureusement connu une forte
augmentation avec cette situation
nationale et donc il faut réagir et donc
pour réagir il ya plusieurs façons de le
faire il ya déjà l'enjeu sur la la
formation la formation de nos jeunes
pour les mettre en adéquation avec les
besoins des entreprises
et puis les démesures des aides
concrètes qui sont apportés directement
à nos pme et à nos grands groupes alors
il ya l'emploi mais dans leurs votes
délégation il ya aussi la formation
professionnelle mais aussi
l'apprentissage quand on parle
d'apprentissage on parle d'alternance
d'une formation en alternance pour les
jeunes là aussi il va falloir aider et
accompagner les jeunes pour trouver leur
alternance mais à écouter vous avez
intégré le mot raison une des premières
mesures qui est adoptée cédé cet été un
sommet requins dédié aux métiers du
numérique avec près de 90 inscrits
actuellement gratuit pour les 16 25 ans
pour se former gratuitement à tous les
métiers du numérique sur les objets
connectés sur la donner sur la
programmation
donc c'est quand même une première
réponse assez inédite pour un territoire
comme le nôtre il ya également un
certain nombre d'autres initiatives qui
vont être lancées je pense au mentorat
ou des salariés saint quentinois vont
pouvoir coacher et ouvrir leurs réseaux
à des jeunes saint quentinois bouclier
ce partenariat gagnant gagnant
on a également le site qui emploie avec
près de 800 autres d'emploi actuellement
qui centralise toutes les offres
d'emploi de nos entreprises à
destination des saint quentinois
et puis il y aura la journée ce qui
emploie au vélodrome qui permet vraiment
de réunir les demandeurs d'emplois avec
les entreprises pour connecter
l'offre et la demande d'emploi de
manière très efficace justement la
plateforme sky emploi le site 1 va
s'afficher en bas de notre écran pour à
la fois les demandeurs d'emploi mais
aussi les entreprises qui souhaitent
postuler et proposer leurs offres
d'emploi donc vous l'avez dit un plus de
800 offres d'emploi actuellement sur
cette plateforme
y at il un rebond finalement rebond
constaté sur le territoire saint quentin
en yvelines
écoutez on a des entreprises résiliente
qui ont su s'adapter qui ont su tenir le
coup mais on a comme un impact important
un vernis mot nicolas dainville on parle
d'une explosion des défaillances
d'entreprises dans les prochains mois à
venir dans le second semestre de 2020 on
parle aussi d'une explosion du chômage
conséquence de ces défaillances quel est
votre regard sur sa est ce que vous êtes
inquiet bien évidemment on est inquiet
d'autant plus qu'il ya un risque de
deuxième vague et un de kovy de 19
quelques alertes qui nous sont
transmises par les personnels soignants
qui sont en première ligne donc il ya
effectivement une inquiétude mais je
pense qu'on est un territoire avec
notamment à sa tête un nouveau président
jean michel fourgous qui a une une
exigence de résultats sur ces enjeux là
avec une motivation des équipes
compétentes
donc voilà je suis bien déçu évidemment
inquiet au niveau national mais rassurés
au niveau local parce que je sais qu'on
a une structure avec des compétences
techniques dans nos équipes dans au sein
des agents et puis avec une motivation
politique
pour vraiment ne rien lâcher sur la
question de l'emploi et du développement
économique
merci nicolas dainville merci à vous
nouveau vice président en charge de
l'emploi de la formation professionnelle
et de l'apprentissage
[Musique]
c'est l'institut international de
l'image et du son a planté à elancourt
le campus troisième forme aux métiers du
cinéma de l'animation des jeux vidéo ou
encore de l'art vivant des formations
allant du bac + 3 au bac + 5 heures
rencontre avec la nouvelle directrice
générale du campus saint quentinois
avec elle nous faisons un bilan de la
continuité pédagogique pendant la crise
sanitaire et parlons de la rentrée 2020
en compagnie de la nouvelle directrice
générale du campus troisième paris à
elancourt christelle mesnage bonjour
bonjour merci de nous recevoir dans
l'établissement 3 i/s
alors voilà nous sommes deux mois après
le déconfinement quel bilan faites-vous
à la fois de la période coded et du
déconfinement et du suivi pédagogique
des étudiants troisième alors la période
qu'ovide a été je pense très
efficacement menée par nos équipes
pédagogiques
mais pas que puisque on a eu également
un énorme support de notre dsi pour tout
ce qui a été mise en place de cours à
distance pour pouvoir garantir un
maximum de cours théoriques à distance à
nos étudiants donc notamment par la mise
en place et l'utilisation de plateformes
est en tout cas de logiciels tels que
tim smalls ou lorsqu'on parle de deux
cours un peu de cours d'amphi donc cette
continuité pédagogique elle a été
garanti pour une majeure partie des
cours maintenant comme vous le savez on
est dans un domaine ou dans des domaines
d'activité l'audiovisuel le spectacle
vivant l'animation jeux vidéo où
effectivement est bien présent ciel une
manipulation technique est nécessaire
donc pour tout ce qui est période de
production qui est quand même
l'aboutissement des cursus de nos
étudiants ces périodes ont été décalés
dans l'emploi du temps donc dans le
planning
elles sont décalés à septembre donc
effectivement on va avoir une sorte de
chevauchement entre les rentrées et ce
qui permettra à nos étudiants de malgré
tout pouvoir maintenir cette continuité
pédagogique et de disposer de l'ensemble
des compétences nécessaires
ensuite effectivement sur la face de
déconfinement aux alentours du 11 12 mai
nous avons mis le bâtiment effectivement
en ordre de marche donc le fléchage
comme vous pouvez le voir au sol mais
également la signalétique les
distributeurs de gel hydroalcoolique la
commande et la réception de masque bien
évidemment pour que les étudiants qui
progressivement ont repris les cours
puissent être masquée dans les locaux et
respecter les gestes barrières et la
distanciation physique donc l'école
c'était effectivement mise en ordre de
marche pour pouvoir à la fois assurer
cette continuité pédagogique pendant le
confinement est ensuite poste
confinement pouvoir progressivement
rouvrir
vous allez devoir assumer à la fois les
étudiants qui vont arriver à la
prochaine rentrée 2020 mais vous avez
aussi à avoir a assuré
les étudiants qui ont fait leur rentrée
en 2019 tout à fait tout à fait ça va
être la difficulté effectivement de
cette année où je dirais une
organisation un petit peu différente qui
a nécessité de nos équipes pédagogiques
et notamment aussi de la direction des
études et de la direction pédagogique et
bien d'aménager des plannings de
réorganiser de repenser complètement on
va dire la matrice du planning de
l'ensemble de nos filières puisque
troisième c'est quand même 1500
étudiants sur quinze mille mètres carrés
sur deux bâtiments
donc effectivement
on apparente ça parfois un petit jeu de
tetris est effectivement lorsqu'on a une
continuité assurée de ce qui n'a pas été
dispensé pendant la période de
confinement cela a nécessité
effectivement des adaptations planning
est effectivement une sorte de
réorganisation pour pouvoir permettre et
bien l'ensemble des filières de pouvoir
avoir les enseignements qui leur sont
destinés un dernier mot sur l'impact
call it sur le projet de développement
de l'établissement
troisième à elancourt alors le projet de
développement de troisième à l encours
est en plein essor on va dire en tout
cas sur plein de sur plein de sujets
n'avaient connu deux langues
alors pas véritablement en tout cas pas
à ce stade je pense qu'il nous faudra
attendre peut-être encore une fois
quelques mois à l'avenir pour pouvoir le
constater
néanmoins ceci dit nous ne nous sommes
pas arrêtés dans nos démarches puisque
nous faisons l'acquisition d'un bâtiment
qui est juste à côté du bâtiment dans
lequel nous sommes rue blaise pascal qui
sera un bâtiment dédié à l'univers
animations jeux vidéo donc véritablement
avec un environnement qui doit être
différent en tout cas puisqu'on à des
populations différentes
on a aussi effectivement des technicité
des métiers qui sont aussi alors on va
dire à ses connexes avec certaines
passerelle mais qui nécessite d'avoir un
environnement véritablement dédié donc
ça c'est aussi deux mille mètres carrés
en plus donc ils viendront s'ajouter aux
15000 donc c'est déjà aussi une force
qui attendent véritablement nos
étudiants et puis un projet de
développement sur notre stratégie là à
l'international qui cette année là en
effet je rejoins votre propos sera bien
évidemment impacté puisque nous avons
des étudiants qui viennent des quatre
coins du monde et en effet l'obtention
de visas va être un peu plus compliqué
donc on a décalé aussi nos rentrées
néanmoins on ne sait pas on sait qu'il
ya d'autres pays qui sont encore impacté
par le cos vide et qui font que ben
voilà sont toujours confinés
néanmoins on a un projet important de
développement qui se poursuivra jusqu'en
2024 sur des créations de filières en
bachelor et en master destiné à une
offre complètement international et
enfin ce que j'oubliais nous disposons
d'une résidence étudiante qui compte
plus de 200 chambres est également le
projet
de construire sur cette fin sur ce
terrain de cette résidence étudiants
qu'une autre résidence étudiante pour
pouvoir permettre à nos étudiants de
pouvoir se loger de pouvoir évoluer les
livres dans ce beau département en tout
cas tranquillement et suivre leurs
études
plusieurs projets un suivi quand on
pourra poursuivre sur les 78 merci merci
albinos merci beaucoup
nouvelle directrice générale du campus
troisième paris à elancourt
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivis et merci pour votre
fidélité c'était le dernier numéro de
mode d'emploi à la rentrée vous
retrouverez une nouvelle formule de
votre magazine de l'économie intitulé
sky et co 13 minutes de décryptage de la
vie économique des formations et de
l'emploi sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]